ah
nos dirigimos a bruselas para hablar con
el secretario general de la otan
rothenberg y me acompaña también nuestro
comentador de asuntos internacionales
douglas
secretario general muchas gracias por su
tiempo usted y yo tenemos edad
suficiente para acordarnos de la guerra
fría algunas cosas que eran impensables
es una semana ahora parecen altamente
probables teme que esta guerra pueda
extenderse a un miembro de la otan
primero que todo es imposible no estar
conmovido y realmente sentir dolor
al ver las imágenes de todo el
sufrimiento que está ocurriendo en
ucrania
los civiles que han muerto y los daños
devastadores que vemos en todo el país
ostente
la responsabilidad principal de la otan
es por supuesto proteger y defender a
todos sus aliados y por esa razón
tenemos la responsabilidad de
asegurarnos que este conflicto no escale
más allá de ucrania y no involucre a los
países de la otan
esta es la razón por la cual hemos
aumentado significativamente la
presencia de las fuerzas de la otan en
la zona este de la alianza en tierra mar
y aire para darle un mensaje muy claro a
moscú de que estamos allí para defender
y proteger a todos los aliados y lo
hacemos preservando la paz previniendo
un ataque a un país aliado de la otan
el secretario general usted ha dejado
muy claro que la otan es una alianza
defensiva
que no es el agresor en este conflicto y
tonio busca ser parte de este conflicto
que tanto les preocupa a usted ya sus
socios en la otan la confrontación
accidental que pueda llevar a una
escalada obviamente indeseada
esto no parece tan improbable dado que
lo hemos visto en el campo de batalla
de las ciudades ucranianas
vladimir putin está demostrando que no
necesariamente necesita ser provocado
para usar a la untable ser un agresor
que tanto le preocupa una confrontación
accidental que pueda llevar a una
escalada
y debemos hacer todo lo posible por
prevenir que ocurra un incidente o un
accidente que involucra a los países
aliados de la otan
y si ocurre debemos asegurarnos de que
no salga de control y genere algo que
sea todavía peor a lo que estamos viendo
hoy es decir una guerra total que
involucra la otan ya rusia
esa es también la razón por la cual
insisto en que necesitamos líneas de
comunicación militares una vez escalada
del conflicto con rusia para asegurarnos
de minimizar el riesgo de accidentes y
que también podamos ser capaces de
manejarlo si ocurre nuestro principal
objetivo es hacer un llamado a rusia
para que les ponga fin a la guerra que
retire sus ropas y también brindarle
apoyo a ucrania pero además por supuesto
asegurarnos de prevenir una escalada
hacia países aliados de la otan de
ucrania volodymyr selenski le ha pedido
a europa que envía a su país aviones de
combate para ayudar a frenar la invasión
rusa quisiera saber cómo está la
situación en ese sentido y de ser el
caso en pilotear a esos aviones
los aliados han entrenado decenas de
miles de tropas kenianas
han proporcionado armas antitanque los
sistemas de defensa contra misiles
y muchas otras veces equipo militar
systems
andan uno después del otro extremo
importante de costes todo esto demuestra
ser extremadamente importante porque
está ayudando a las valientes fuerzas
armadas de ucrania a oponerse a las
fuerzas invasoras rusas
el ejército ucraniano está mejor
equipado mejor entrenado y es mucho más
grande ahora que en 2014 seguiremos y
seguimos brindándoles apoyo
no entrar en detalles acerca de qué tipo
de apoyo estamos brindando a los
distintos aliados de la otan pero lo
estamos haciendo y los aliados están
reforzando el apoyo a ucrania y
usted habla de brindar apoyo y esto es
obviamente un pilar de lo que tan puede
hacer en un cráneo si no puede mandar
tropas al terreno me preguntáis cómo
están llegando a esas armas al campo de
batalla logísticamente como las está
enviando la otan quien las está llevando
al campo de batalla y una vez que están
ahí en manos de las fuerzas ucranianas
cuánto tiempo debe pasar antes de que
realmente puedan usar esas armas y las
hagan efectivas operacionalmente
amberger fuego youtube del soldado por
típica acción de bandera personal a este
soporte para las apps soy muy cuidadoso
con no entrar en detalles al respecto
en parte porque puede minar los
esfuerzos de los aliados para brindar
apoyo a los aliados han anunciado que el
equipo militar ha llegado a manos de las
fuerzas ucranianas
pero más allá de eso no entraré en
detalles
porque lo que importa ahora es que los
aliados están brindando apoyo y que
estamos ayudando y apoyando a las tropas
ucranianas la valentía que demuestran la
valentía que demuestra la población
ucraniana y también la valentía y el
compromiso del presidente excelencia y
de los líderes ucranianos inspiran al
mundo entero a brindar apoyo y es
extremadamente importante que ahora
brindamos apoyo militar
pero también humanitario y financiero
ucrania
pero la situación secretario general
revela la incómoda posición en la que se
encuentra la otan
quiero saber que puedan ser la otan
teniendo en cuenta que cualquier cosa
que haga puede resultar en una guerra
mucho más grande y peligrosa
y claro
bueno nos hemos estado preparando para
esto desde hace tiempo porque la
inteligencia de la otan yo y en
particular la de estados unidos predijo
que esto podría pasar hace muchos meses
tratamos de encontrar una solución
política pero el presidente último
decide usar la fuerza militar contra
ucrania
por lo tanto en las últimas semanas y
meses los aliados han aumentado su apoyo
a ucrania
pero también hemos dejado claro que no
entraremos a ucrania con tropas de la
otan o al espacio aéreo de ucrania con
aviones de la otan
y nos ayudamos a mantener su derecho de
legítima defensa
ese es el derecho de toda nación
soberana establecido en la carta de las
naciones unidas hacemos eso pero no
somos parte del conflicto y no
desplegamos tropas de la otan en el
terreno o aviones de la otan en el aire
el ministerio de asuntos exteriores ruso
ha prevenido que cualquier intento de
finlandia y suecia por unirse a la
alianza por acercarse a la alianza
tendría los hitos y serias consecuencias
políticas y militares que le contesta a
rusia
y
[Música]
esa es una declaración totalmente
inaceptable por parte de rusia porque va
en contra del principio fundamental de
nuestra seguridad que toda nación tiene
derecho a escoger su propio camino tanto
si quiere o no pertenecer a una alianza
como la otan la expansión de la otan ha
ayudado a difundir la democracia y la
libertad a través de europa durante
décadas desde finales de la guerra fría
respeto absolutamente el derecho
soberano de finlandia y suecia para
decidir su propio futuro
respeto si deciden no solicitar la
adhesión pero si deciden solicitarla por
supuesto tienen el derecho a unirse a la
otan
esa decisión le corresponde a finlandia
y a suecia ya los 30 aliados no a rusia
y ese mensaje cada vez más recurrente
por parte de rusia de que si no
cumplimos con las exigencias habrá lo
que rusia llama consecuencias técnicas
militares es una manera para tratar de
intimidar y amenazar a las naciones
soberanas de europa
rusia hace esto para tratar de que haya
menos sótano pero lo que consigue es más
o tan cerca de las fronteras cuando se
comporta de esa manera tratan de
dividirnos pero están consiguiendo una
otan más unida incluyendo el hecho de
que estamos muy unidos con finlandia y
suecia finlandia y suecia son socios muy
cercanos nunca han estado más cerca
estuvieron presentes en la reunión de
hoy
eso sólo demuestra que rusia el
presidente putin consiguen lo opuesto de
lo que esperan es decir más o sangre una
otan más fuerte y más unida
finalmente el secretario general a parte
del presidente macrón que habla con
vladimir putin hay alguien más y tendido
de la alianza hablando con el líder ruso
[Música]
tenemos líneas de comunicación militares
para des escalar el conflicto para
reducir los riesgos de falta de cálculos
incidentes y accidentes
y los aliados han dejado claro que
estamos listos para emprender diálogos
políticos serios pero al mismo tiempo
debemos estar seguros de que rusia
también se toma en serio los esfuerzos
diplomáticos y hasta el momento han
escogido la guerra las fuerzas armadas
en vez de los esfuerzos diplomáticos
serios sistemáticos ya esto muchas
gracias de nuevo por su tiempo
[Música]